at microsoft's press conference for
gamescom we got to see a trailer for
dark souls 3 that involved a bunch of
gameplay but two individuals here on the
couch got to actually play dark souls 3
now i'm gonna pick their brains for what
all is the deal with that game Mike my
hardy and Mary Kish Dark Souls 3 you
guys got hands-on yeah yeah in a castle
we do for one whole hour and the cathode
yeah alright so did you see yesterday
during the trailer anything that look
familiar was that like from the time
period in the game that you got to play
definitely you from the trailer you can
already see it's the same area that it
normally is in right like the same time
frame it looks like an Armageddon state
or a bunch of buildings that are now
dilapidated it's very dark souls is what
you're trying to say right it's very
like there's medieval weaponry and armor
there's sort of these these castles and
looming cities with bridges and it all
has a very specific look sort of dialing
back the sort of gothic horror look of
blood-borne into a more Dark Souls zone
yeah it's definitely got that Dark Souls
Flair but what you might not have
noticed from the trailer we saw an hour
playthrough was it's more interconnected
world Dark Souls 1 did that really well
where you would go into this crazy path
and when it came back it blooped around
right to the beginning there would be a
gate there that was locked that's how
you come out and use you end up right
where you started and that was something
really lovely that I really enjoyed
about Dark Souls 1 level design and it
wasn't the same in dark souls 2 you went
off into these weaving paths and then
you just turn around and went back but
Dark Soul this new Dark Souls 3 seems
like they're taking a lot of hints from
the original Dark Souls and giving it
this nice interconnected world is there
any sort of the sort of combat mechanics
and gear stuff that you guys noticed it
was interesting yeah so one of the major
additions in Dark Souls 3 which is kind
of dark souls answer to blood-borne Zhou
the trick weapons you could press l1 I
think and it would kind of extend a
weapon or you know plow it into the
piece of concrete to become a hammer
yeah the kur camera was great mm-hmm but
in this in Dark Souls 3 they have weapon
arts now so you just hold a trigger and
you'll kind of do a charge up attack and
then you could do a strong version or
like a more of a you know light-handed
kind of attack if it pends on which
weapon you have to will depend on how
that weapon actually
interacts with the world to have a
longsword it'll be like this giant
overhand maneuver where is if you have a
small sword and maybe a shield it'll be
like a really aggressive thrust forward
there's also these dual weapons yeah
there's scimitars and if you use that l2
stance you do a spin attack which
aerials everyone around you which is
really amazing if you're surrounded by
enemies good depending on your scenario
you're you're best off with a different
weapon choice and now this weapon arts
is that like a just a move you have in
your arsenal at all times mm kind of so
each time you get to a bonfire every
sets and you get 20 between bonfires to
you so you kind of have to park that you
know parse them out especially said it's
a consumable sort of power kind of like
an Estus flask yeah they're limited I'm
not sure if you're going to get upgrades
that increase the quantity between
bonfires but I definitely found myself
trying to save them as much for the boss
as possible then also another kind of
minor which it seem minor at first and I
didn't know this until it kind of
screwed me over um you can only do the
post with like really light kite shields
now anyway like medium or larger shield
you can't do that and I didn't know that
until I died because I tried doing it
trying to do it a bunch but really
you're just meant to sort of stand in
and take it on your heavy shield we got
to play as two classes one was a night
the other was like a brute kind of with
an axe who had more powerful attacks but
it definitely felt a little more like
blood-borne as far as the dodge goes it
felt a little more forgiving and you
know I spoke to the Purdue like a
producer for the game and they said you
know they're still very much keeping
Dark Souls its own franchise you're not
gonna make it blood-borne they're not
gonna make blood-borne like Dark Souls
down the road but they are kind of blood
souls yeah borrowing from each other
this stamina was regen agree alee really
fast so i think that they they're taking
some stuff from blood-borne and letting
you kind of fight a bit faster a bit
quicker they want faster paced movement
but they are still giving the the
original vibe depending on your play
style if you get that long sword and you
have a really heavy attack you're not
gonna be moving a lot they're taking
elements that you might have seen before
and they're revamping them and they're
making something new so it's not the
same as just stealing from a game
they're they're taking elements that
they feel we're successful and made the
game
better and and I think they're just kind
of fine-tuning that and from what we
played so far it's a really nice mix of
faster movement but you still need to
time your movements properly to survive
and to continue in that world
you